có vị quét công dân có viện dài đi mức thái tích hợp đủ năm dài tờ ngon.
Giải kai xinh thông tin thẻ ngon hàng, tài khoảng thành trón, vi định tờ,
tài khoảng tiền gì đâu, thông tin tài khoảng an xinh giá hội, thông tin số 3 bào gì đâu.
Sổ xức khoảng định tờ sẽ được miến lệ phi đang kỳ,
cấp biển fun tiện giáu thông cầu dưới đường bộ,
miến lệ phi cấp lối cấp lại thẻ cắn cơ.
Gỳ quét cụ quy định giảm mời phần chăm mất thủ lệ phi trước bà.
Lột bình nhà rất nhận chuyển nhớ khi đang kỳ quét xả hiểu quét xe dụng,
chỉ ám dụng một lần dưới nhá trong một năm,
mất giảm tử ra không quán năm lần mất lần cơ xờ,
tài thời điểm kê khai lệ phi trước bà.
Chính xanh lệ ám dụng lối với công dân sự dụng tài khoảng định gián dịch tử,
mất nổ thật hiện khai và nổ plệ phi trước bà,
bằng hình thức hiện tử theo hình dẫn của công quán thẻ,
và đáp ứng cứ được kiện tụi thế.
Nó là đã tích hợp thành công trên ứng dụng viện EID,
thông tin mà sổ thề cải nhắn, thông tin về quyền xe dụng lất,
quyền xả hiểu tại sản của bến chuyển nhớ và năm lỗi thông tin,
giấy tờ cơ bàn khai quy định trên.